why is it always multiverses now and I
was like I don't [__] know because
they ran out of other [__] to talk about
I don't know I am sick and tired of
[__] multiverses do you know do you
know why they comic books or at least
not like not conference no no it's not
just that it's um they've just reached
the Dragon Ball problem where you've
you've taken on the biggest threat of
the world yeah and then you take on the
biggest threat of the Galaxy which is
[__] Thanos where'd you go what are
you doing where do you go after you save
the entire universe what about other
universes we should follow Jojo and then
dislikes JoJo you know obviously had
part three which is a battle across the
entire Earth and then the next season
they were like how about we just have a
little problem in this little town and
then it was actually amazing it was so
good because they sure he just he was
like [__] it no let's just shrink this
down let's make this all contained in a
single location and then we can really
experiment with that I think I think
that's what they need to do an imposters
like what if we didn't do that I think
yeah and then part eight is like let's
just [__] do LSD yeah right you know
I think we'll come back we'll have the
LSD Arc I'm sure but I think I think I
would appreciate if it was you know a
bit more ground which is why I like kind
of like uh so what you're Batman yeah
Batman's Slice of Life the the Batman
was kind of like that it was all
contending Gotham yeah one small kind of
scary God you know you know I realized
recently when we're never going to get
another Thanos moment are we I was I was
I was really cool yeah I was re-watching
uh like Infinity war and like end game
Clips just like what's wrong with you
Carl what's wrong with me why are you
what re-watching movie clips all the
time because I would like to relive some
of like the moments you know sometimes
I'm just can't be bothered to watch the
whole film you know you know with the
state of the MCU at the moment I'm like
that Wolverine you know that Wolverine
image like just like embracing the scene
from like endgame to be like oh remember
the good old days because you know I I
you know obviously we did realize how
big it was back when it first aired but
I'm like man we really did have we
really did have our Luke I am your
father moment didn't we like that that
was you know I I still never and you
never [__] saw it because you hate
popular stuff no I hate Marvel
I respect that I wish I didn't I'm
trying to get sucked into this [__]
pit that I hate yeah I watch all of them
and I hate them all yeah exactly I just
get angry yeah I still watch them I
don't know why did you eat them before
like end game I started getting pretty
tired of them before it oh really I mean
the last few movies before endgame and
infinity War were kind of ass you gotta
admit
they can't they they went and came
pretty cool we are like Thor three which
was like the best of the Thor series I
didn't even know there were three
yeah
Ant-Man 2 which sucked we had uh Captain
Marvel which Captain Marvel sucks we got
a [__] black panther my father was
good right never saw that that was quite
a while before though okay that was
quite a while before I think I remember
watching it was it was close yeah it was
like the I think it was like the year
before I definitely started feeling like
Marvel fatigue
right before with that end game was like
all right let's do it I'm [__] tired
about talking about endgame we talked
about endgame so Marvel I hate Marvel so
much I'm done I'm done
Spiderman Spiderman it's the new cool
thing now Spider-Man in my head I kind
of like it was nice because I felt like
the spider verse was like oh my God it's
out of Marvel like it is Marvel property
but it's not in the [__] [__]
Universal everything yeah and just
visually it's just a breath of fresh air
as well you know you know what yeah I um
actually sad because I've because
that's it okay
but you know you know what like are the
DC films actually underrated no actually
already just released the flash actually
featuring a man who's Crazy wait you're
gonna have to list it out for me because
I've only ever seen Batman which Batman
like
most of the Batman films I've seen have
you seen Batman vs Superman yeah I did
that [__] sucked okay name a good uh DC
film recently that isn't Batman okay
I know when when I talk about DC I
specifically am talking about the whole
the whatever the Schneider verse
I mean did you what did you watch the
slide I'm not watching the I'm not
watching a [__] who watches
me I watch the Snyder and how awesome um
probably the best version of the the
best movie in the Schneider verse so far
am I what other films there in the
Schneider verse
um
Superman what was the new what was the
Superman called Man of Steel Man it was
Man of Steel and then Batman vs Superman
yeah and then it was Justice League
um okay but okay here's the thing here's
the thing I am sad that it got cut off
because I like the fact that I there
there are some absolutely Banger amazing
scenes in like okay they aren't good
films but they had some really
interesting ideas in them
um like one of my one of the I've seen
that sticks out to me I think I've
talked about this before was the
beginning of Batman vs Superman where
you see where you see Batman's
perspective the POV shot yeah the POV
shot of just Superman and okay yeah that
was pretty cool and like the other
person uh Zod just wrecking the city up
and you just realize holy [__] [__]
me as a human being I have absolutely
zero power and zero stake in whatever
the [__] they decide to fight over you
see an apps you see a city getting
wrecked and you feel so
um you see you feel so humbled right
because you feel like Batman is just
totally [__] powerless right and I
really like the con I really like that
idea the idea that they played around
that uh where you just see basically
Hume Superman being treated as a God and
then that's like a fake God because if
you think about it Superman kind of is a
God you know compare compared to what's
called like power yeah but how's the
ending how's the ending yeah the ending
sucked you know I know the first five
minutes of the Batman POV was the only
like good shot in the film yeah I feel
yeah the rest of it it just got worse
and worse yeah it it makes me sad
because I feel like some of these ideas
slowly coming into fruition in the
Schneider cuts of you know in in the
Justice League Shiner car where you you
kind of feel some of these ideas getting
to breathe a bit more and then obviously
it just got cut and uh we we have
something completely new now but it was
a breath of fresh air just to see a
totally serious take on superheroes that
didn't have equip every [__] five
minutes and just someone just seeing
someone try to just
portray a much darker side of
superheroes a much more serious side and
then he had the whole [__] Martha
thing and then everyone just checked out
and you're like okay whatever what else
is there in the DC side of things
because uh the only thing the only again
I'm not knowledgeable on DC [__] the
only thing I know is Batman there's
Wonder Woman which was a thing whereas
like who watched that which was uh I
mean first one was okay it was awful
yeah uh is Flash DC or is that yeah
flash is DC oh yeah cause that's having
a great time yeah yeah I don't know I I
don't know why it's just when I watch a
d when I watch all of like squeaky's
chat existence when I watch the DC films
I'm like these are the most 5 out of 10
films with some 10 out of 10 ideas in
them that never get realized and it
makes me sad it makes me sad because
they have the potential to be reading I
think the best piece of superhero media
right now is just the boys yeah the
thing I enjoyed out of everything I've
watched in like the past since end game
that's by far the most thing I've
enjoyed Invincible as well
which is like it's not even any of these
guys and it's it's just a TV and it's
like this is great sure yeah it's not a
[__] stupid quick every two [__]
seconds making a joke it's like you know
it's it's diabolical in it she's [__]
yeah it's great I feel like they put
humor in organically and it's not like
quicker it's been uh three seconds we
made a funny one-liner guys we gotta
write something so
um
I feel like [__] off I'm not I'm not an
idiot like I don't need a [__] every
two seconds I feel like it works when
it's someone like [__] Iron Man with
Robert Downey Jr it would yeah that's
just his character yeah every character
needed to quit but even then after a
while it just got old or I'm just like
all right yeah we get and they turned
Thor into like this very serious it used
to be a very serious character and I
admit he was too rigid but now they just
turned him into like just a budget like
Tony Stark impersonator one-line quick
thing it's just like this is boring yeah
and then and then you're like okay guys
but now we have Chris Pratt who does the
exact same [__] thing and then it's
like all right but then and then
everyone else slash yeah it's just like
everyone it's like it's like a yeah like
you said it's like a [__] shitty game
of Jack box and Cards Against Humanity
everyone's trying to be the funniest
person in the room and it's like not
everyone needs to be can we have a
superhero movie where there's just like
zero one-liners no that would be that
would be kind of interesting to see yeah
if it holds up and it was like even in
Guardians of Galaxy when I watched that
it was like yeah it was like the only
person who really consistently landed
them was like the uh muscle big guy
what's his name
Batista yeah he was his matched his
character all the time when Chris Pratt
did it I was like okay all right because
scratch just just be Chris Pratt stop
um you know so that was fun but
um yeah I I that's my opinions on yeah I
mean yeah yeah at the end of it I'm
excited to watch you will like it yeah
I'm sure yeah tldr spider-verse great
everyone everyone knows Twitter won't
shut the [__] up about it yeah like it's
impossible to avoid spoilers what it
taught me is that maybe we don't have
superhero fatigue maybe we just have mid
superhero movie fatigue yeah you know
yeah bold take
maybe we have bad movies not only the
spices take the trash
um I actually I I I've watched the um
Dungeons and dragon movie so I don't say
this oh no that was actually really good
really yeah I don't know why it had to
be Dungeons and Dragons
it could have just been a fantasy film
well I think because they use a lot of
stuff that was in Dungeons and Dragons
in the like a lot of the creatures it
was good though yeah it was very fun
genuinely a pretty fun movie was it good
or was it just like acceptable no it was
fun it was good it was like actually
good okay
um it was very fun I had a great set
about it
uh dragons and dungeons like is it is it
done in though I know and I thought it
was going to be like a They're all
playing a game yeah
it's not like Never Ending Story
sometimes it's not like we have a
conversation every [__] you know yeah
I thought going into it it was going to
be people playing Dungeons and Dragons
and then it would be acting acting out
the scenes and it could be like well you
rolled a four oh I'll get critical hit
oh something like that you know I
thought it's gonna be like that and I
just didn't I I didn't want that yeah
and luckily wasn't that it was literally
just a fantasy thing okay that was just
used aspect of what I again I don't know
I don't play Dungeons and Dragons I
don't know which aspects were licensed
or not yeah I think spells Monsters
characters that were from Dungeons and
Dragons in the story right right but it
was like a uh kind of like a heist gone
wrong I don't remember what actually
they ever introduced the dice roll
aspect no no no there's never a Dungeons
there's basically Dungeons and Dragons
characters
yeah it's basically just the a campaign
of Dungeons and Dragons kind of yeah
it's literally just imagine a campaign
but there was no there's no fourth wall
yeah because I thought for sure they
were going to do like what they did with
like Never Ending Story where it's like
there's a perspective of like them
playing there is a narrator
it's not from a person playing the
character it's from the character's
perspective narrates a little bit in the
start of your backstory but that's
during I mean it's all within the story
uh it's fun genuinely funny moments
um good honestly I I kind of hope it
does well because I'd love to see
another one I just want more fantasy I
want more fantasy well I I don't want
more superhero I want more fantasy I
know what you're gonna say let me tell
you an entire thing
let me tell you an entire genre where
you can find them no no he wants good
fantasy I want good fantasy not big
tittied women who harems uh what good
I'll bring me back Lord of the Rings
give me elves and and uh [__] dwarfs
I just want to get me with the boys
going on a journey I don't need MILF
some [__] lollies or anything like
this [__] get the hell out of here now
give me Michelle too man I I that's
that's coming out next that's next
season I am very very excited that's
what I made Lord of the Rings the goat
it's just the boys on a journey that's
what made himself just the [__] boys
trying to get rid of the the One Ring
you know I mean you got the Golem video
game right
yeah nobody wanted that I've heard so
much about that but like I don't know
the details of it I just heard that a
lot of people are hating on it yeah
because it's literally just it's more
buggy than cyberpunk when it came out
and it wasn't even a good game to begin
with it's [__] the tell the odd [__]
even like so do you oh so you're gonna
have to explain this to me so do you
play as gold yeah yes
which is conceptually already the worst
[__] idea he's the least no one is
out of all the characters in Lord of the
Rings yeah there's a character that
nobody wanted to play as was [__]
Golem yeah give me a Legolas game yeah
you know what I mean come on something
you know anything
what I would love her who asked who
asked for this no one else yeah no one
asked give me like a heavy strategy game
Lord of the Rings where it's like Age of
Empires Lord of the Rings
come here give me a [__] movie that
is just in a similar inspired world
that's not [__] I don't know I'm
[__] done it's it's it's like doing a
Harry Potter video game be like uh what
I think people want to play as Dobby
actually I think that'd be really
interesting gameplay what's Dobby up to
like
exactly the same you know it's just like
who thought who thought playing as
Gollum would be a good [__] idea yeah
I don't know I just want more fantasy
and less I'm hoping it because you know
we've had a big upswing in fantasy
hoping because this movie kind of did I
think it did pretty well yeah I hope we
get more fantasy movies we'd love to see
more fantasy I mean kind of like the
tolkieners kind of fantasy ah it doesn't
have to be that just kind of more set in
like kind of a medieval period or just
kind of an older period because you know
Game of Thrones popped off too as Dragon
popped off yeah dragons popped off it's
clearly him let's get more I do not want
more fantasy I don't want more Lord of
the Rings I want more sci-fi I miss
sci-fi so [__] much okay can we agree
we all agree as the Council of [__]
takes okay yeah less superhero more
sci-fi more more yeah just less
superheroes yeah actually those those
I've been preaching this for years
please